[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates in
the movies art thieves are portrayed
like the debonair Thomas crown but this
man knows different Tim Carpenter is the
FBI agent who runs the bureau's art
theft squad that tracks down art thieves
this is all about making money
so no it's not Thomas Crown Affair
Carpenter's best-known successes have
involved the recovery of the ruby red
slippers used by Dorothy and The Wizard
of Oz and the Jersey stolen from New
England Patriots quarterback Tom Brady
right after the Super Bowl but what
about the theft almost 30 years ago at
the Isabella Stewart Gardner Museum in
Boston the empty frames a reminder of
what was taken and what remains missing
you think it's still in the country
well perhaps plus our shout out to the
high school journalism teacher who was
threatened with her job after approving
a story in the student newspaper about a
student who was also working in the
pornography industry I love my job I
love my students I will always protect
their right to free speech from the law
in crime Network studios in New York
City's Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and welcome
tonight we take a close look at a crime
that has inspired books and movies and
caught the imagination of so many the
theft of priceless pieces of art
paintings sculpture and as we are about
to see so much more the FBI lists more
than 7,000 stolen objects it is trying
to find led by a special art theft squad
whose lead agent is going public tonight
hear about the case that is number one
on his priority list but as we
discovered it's not just Rembrandt's and
Picasso's that get the FBI's attention
there's no place like there's no place
like home over the years those ruby red
slippers worn by Dorothy and the beloved
movie The Wizard of Oz have become a
pop-culture treasure
[Music]
why have you done with them so when
someone broke into the Judy Garland
Museum in Minnesota and stole one of the
four sets of slippers used during the
movie production it was for many fans a
very big deal
where are Dorothy's ruby red slippers
wee slippers were taken during a
smash-and-grab
a big enough deal it turns out for FBI
headquarters to assign the bureau's
elite art theft squad to go find the
slippers the issue there was that what
an important piece of Americana that is
right under the rainbow
how can you describe that what an
amazing recovery that was Tim Carpenter
is the FBI agent at headquarters who
runs the bureau's 20 person art death
squad they've recovered stolen
Rembrandt's and other great pieces of
art and continue to investigate huge
unsolved thefts at major museums but
Carpenter says Dorothy slippers were
also a worthy subject for his group
we're well known for the cases that we
do and we're recovering Renaissance art
or old masters or whatnot you know and
so a lot of times people see that we're
recovering art for the rest of the world
this was a case where we were able to
recover our own cultural property well
13 years after they were stolen the ruby
slippers Judy Garland wore in The Wizard
of Oz have been found it's funny what
you get headlines for you also recovered
the Tom Brady shirt yeah oh we did yeah
in the moments after New England
Patriots quarterback Tom Brady led his
team to the Super Bowl someone made off
with his game Jersey and again FBI
headquarters sent in Tim carpenters art
theft squad it's not historic and yet it
has this huge cultural value for people
did you feel that was sort of beneath
you in any way no we don't view cases in
that regard right we looked at each case
as that cultural value it's not about
intrinsic value or monetary or market
value of a piece it was the looting of
the Iraqi National Museum in Baghdad in
2004 15 years ago that led to the
creation of the FBI's dedicated our
theft squad we just simply didn't have
enough folks that had the requisite
knowledge how to handle identify collect
and process culture property so that was
a lesson that that incident taught us
and that's what kind of was the genesis
for the creation of our team in our
program and where does that
investigation stand how much of that art
has been recovered not much not nearly
enough so and we you know it still is up
on our on our top 10 art Crimes list
since you came aboard here or three
years ago what's been the most
significant case you've cracked a couple
of years ago we recovered a Norman
Rockwell painting that had been missing
for three decades
you know the de Kooning painting from
the University of Arizona that
recovered last year those are really
significant in remarkable cases but
today no case has had the impact of what
the FBI art theft team discovered in
this private home in the middle of an
Indiana cornfield it is a collection
worthy of its own Museum some 42,000
items
Miller's collection was no secret
friends and neighbors had all seen it
schools even brought kids on field trips
to his home inside a giant collection of
Antiquities relics human remains
essentially stolen looted and on display
inside it was the first time that we had
successfully deployed the team and how
did you get onto what was the break in
that case that came in to us as a tip
interviewing this gentleman and he's
describing me to the describing to me
this collection and he kept using the
word huge or you know enormous he was
talking about it in those terms and of
course I had to stop him father say well
what do you mean by huge or enormous
because again my experience maybe it's
yeah three or four hundred pieces and
I'll never forget that he told me well
you know I'm not really sure but I think
it's about two hundred thousand pieces
the owner an 85 year old collector by
the name of Don Miller who died the year
after the FBI showed up at his home he
was pretty forthcoming with the
information he talked to me you know I
had a nauseum about his collection and
was very forthcoming about how he
obtained it and many of the instances
and objects he we would discuss he would
talk to us about the illicit nature in
which he had detained it he didn't
hesitate to say that to an FBI agent he
did not in a huge operation the FBI took
possession of all that was inside
Miller's home to this day agents still
don't have a clear idea of who the
rightful owners really are in most cases
we don't many of the items appeared have
been taken from Native American burial
grounds requiring very sensitive
handling as detailed in a video the FBI
has posted on its website and we want to
make sure that we can properly
culturally affiliate that piece to the
right tribal group or the right
indigenous group and make sure it gets
returned where it's supposed to the
FBI's database of stolen art objects now
totals around seven
we have Persian rugs you know musical
instruments
you name it Stradivarius violins and and
whatnot so if you can think of it in the
terms of the cultural property world we
probably have that on our website we're
very busy we're very busy
is there one theft one issue you really
want to solve number one on your own
personal list the Gardner Museum we
would really like to get those paintings
recovered the Isabella Stewart Gardner
Museum in Boston thieves broke in or
were led in 29 years ago on a st.
Patrick's Day night the next morning 13
pieces of art were gone paintings
cut out of their frames some experts are
calling it the biggest art theft in US
history the art world was distraught a
half billion dollars worth of art that
remains missing to this day are you
close
well I'm not going to comment on that
that's that's for the field office to to
engage coming up on 30 years since then
art was stolen
yeah do you think the art still exists I
like to think so I hope so do you think
it's still in the country
well perhaps only perhaps perhaps teams
of law enforcement agents have swarmed
the home of a reputed mobster FBI agents
have traveled to six continents dug up
the lawns of elderly mobsters and
pursued hundreds of leads all to no
avail
at one point the FBI and federal
prosecutors essentially claimed they
were close to solving the crime there's
been a significant development in the
investigation over the last couple of
years to the point where we can say with
a high degree of certainty that we
believe we've identified the individuals
who were responsible for the original
theft and in fact we've been able to
trace some of the paintings their
whereabouts that was six years ago still
no paintings no arrests despite a 10
million dollar reward offered by the
museum and I would have thought that you
know
the reward has been sizeable and
significant of course and then they
doubled the reward you would like to
think and we've had successes lots of
successes historically with the rewards
but has it really seemed to nudge it
loose on this case so I'm not quite sure
what it's going to take we just need
that one good viable tip from the public
at this point are you more interested in
recovering the yard or finding the
people responsible well you know of
course we're very interested in the safe
recovery and the full recovery of all of
that artwork would you let someone walk
if they turned in the art well that's
not my decision to make so you know the
Boston field office has that
investigation and the US Attorney's
Office in Boston that would be a
decision they would make in the
announcement six years ago the then US
attorney in Boston Carmen Ortiz did
offer the possibility of immunity an
immunity as a potential for someone who
may have knowledge of or has actual
knowledge may have had involvement in
the concealment throughout the years of
these arts of work would be available to
them and I'm here to confirm that again
but no one has since come forward would
you call it a cold case at this point I
would think it's a cold case because we
do get a fair amount of information on
that case right so we still we still
address a lot of leads on that
investigation but look we've been very
successful on cold cases just in the
last few years we've solved a number of
cold cases that were 30 35 and 40 years
old so it's not that uncommon especially
high-end when we're talking really
valuable really well-known pieces that
would disappear and kind of go to ground
for decades before they resurface so we
we hold out hope that we will locate
those pieces so at this point you
wouldn't say it's been a failed
investigation certainly not no it
certainly not I wouldn't say that it
continues it continues and so there's
not a period of time you're gonna give
up and say I guess it's gone no I don't
think we'll do that do you think you'll
get it before this 30 year anniversary
coming up next st. Patrick's Day I can
only hope right I can only hope but I'd
like to say that if we could solve that
case
- up and retire that might be my swan
song if you have any information you
want to share about the stolen art from
the Gardner Museum or any other case you
can send tips to the FBI's Tim carpenter
at tips dot F bi gov or if you want to
contact me at law and crime calm and
don't forget that Gardner Museum has
offered a reward of ten million dollars
coming up next more on our special
report on art theft it's not as
glamorous as movies like the Thomas
Crown Affair make it appear we'll talk
to one of the top legal experts who
knows how it really works
we continue now with our special report
on art theft we just heard from the FBI
but sometimes in fact oftentimes it
takes more than someone with a badge and
a gun to get to the bottom of the case
in the movies like the Thomas Crown
Affair art thieves are portrayed as
cultured and debonair as they make off
with priceless treasures but we got a
different take on that criminal industry
from this man Christopher Robinson a
former art dealer who now works as a
lawyer helping clients including museums
and collectors recover stolen art or
find out if they've been sold fakes we
talked with him at the Jill Newhouse
gallery in New York City in the movies
we see Thomas Crown the debonair
cultured art see is that what art
thieves are no I don't think so I think
it's possible that from time to time
there's one or two people who will
commission a theft like that for those
kinds of purposes but for the most part
it's it's a way of making some money and
actually it's a very bad way of making
money because this is not a liquid asset
we just heard from the head of the FBI
art theft squad that they're still
looking for the arts told from the
Gardner Museum after almost 30 years is
it realistic to think that can ever be
seen again I think so I mean there's no
way of knowing for sure but those
paintings are so valuable that I really
do feel they'll be found feel that they
will be found again that one of the main
issues though is in what condition I
suspect they'd be moved around a fair
amounts it's the theft and there's
always a risk of damage to them over
that period of time can art that that's
well known known to have been stolen can
never be sold is that is there a market
for it not a legitimate market I mean
there's no way that could be sold at an
auction or or you know in a regular
private way I mean I suspect that those
have those paintings if they do still
exist have passed hands and so there's
some form of collateral either for some
arms for money in some kind money
laundering of some kind and that would
be the normal way that that would be
used because I think the understanding
is that there's there's no way those
works can exit into the legitimate
market is there a way that doesn't
involve law enforcement to recover that
kind of stolen art there are private
companies that that can work on this I
know that if you are a private
individual and you've had a theft there
are companies that can that can work on
this for you
k2 is one I know that does a lot of
investigative work in this area they are
lost register also which has a very
important database of lost works of art
can also be and will also take on an
issue like this to try and find the
works and what about the idea of a
reward or a ransom is that helpful
does it encourage future thefts no I
think a reward is helpful the reward is
going to be probably aimed at a minor
player in all of this for whom it's
going to be a lot of money and I don't
think that those are the people who are
going to be looking for that reward and
not those that stole the work in the
first place here's a question from our
executive producer Rhonda Schwartz Chris
my question for yous about the stolen
Gardner art where do you think it is do
you think it's in the hands of some
wealthy collector who's got it hidden
away in his house in his basement who's
secretly looking at it where do you
think it is I don't think it's like that
I very very much doubt it's on display
anywhere to anybody
these paintings I think often end up
getting packed up buried put in outside
storehouses somewhere it's possible it's
in a free port somewhere the free ports
around the world are very little
regulated and it's very difficult
sometimes to know what's in there and
those are secure ways of keeping art of
this kind and how do you feel about it
when you see that kind of art cultural
values and treasure stone I think it's
horrible obviously anybody with a with a
mind would think that that is a horrible
thing to happen these paintings are on
public view for a reason they're there
for the public to to enjoy that part of
our cultural patrimony and when they're
stolen like that especially if there's a
risk that they're going to get damaged
it's a terrible thing
do you have clients who get offered this
stolen art and how do you make sure it's
legit I hope I don't have clients who
could offer this kind of art I've never
been told by them if they
the the way that a private client needs
to do his due diligence find out if the
work is right or not you can you start
off with a very simple google you can
contact some basic databases the Art
Loss Register based in London keeps a
very good database of art that has been
stolen around the world you can inquire
through Interpol as well there are there
are and also the arm I far it's National
Foundation for art research in New York
keeps good tabs on what work has been
stolen so with the internet it's even
harder than ever to pass stolen art I
think it's become almost impossible
unless it's something a relatively
relatively generic or minor you might
get a 19th century landscape or or maybe
an Italian or master painting by nobody
in particular and that's the kind of
work that would be difficult to pin down
because you may not have an author and
you may not have a an image that is very
memorable that art still continues to be
stolen it does I mean it's it's a great
temptation especially when you see the
kinds of prices that arts bet our
fetchers at auction four hundred and
something million dollars for Leonardo
it obviously is a great temptation
booster for Robeson thank you very much
you're welcome up next our shoutout for
the high school journalism teacher who
put her job on the line to make sure her
students could report stories the school
administration wanted to keep secret
our shout out tonight to a brave and
determined journalism teacher at a
California high school who gave her
students and her bosses a real-life
lesson in how the First Amendment should
work the faculty adviser for the school
newspaper at Bear Creek High School in
Stockton California is Kathy duffle I
love my job
I love my students I will always protect
their right to free speech and she had
to put her job on the line this year
when her students came up with the story
at the school administration well
certainly did not want public we were
sitting around pitching story ideas as
we normally do and one of the students
pitched this story and said you know
I've been hearing a lot about a girl
named Caitlyn on our campus and she has
a sex worker and there's been some
rumors about her and maybe she would
welcome the chance to to set the record
straight
eighteen-year-old Caitlyn Fink agreed to
be interviewed by the student papers
managing editor Bailey Kirkeby when I
first began writing this story it was
supposed to be just another profile of a
student like we do every issue but
Caitlyn's story included how the senior
had been working as a model for a porn
agency selling nude videos of herself
and aspiring to become a stripper it
wasn't even on my radar for me it was
just another student profile that we
were doing but then she received this
threatening letter from the school
superintendent after word quickly spread
about what the student paper was up to
that said that if we were to publish the
story and not submit it for prior review
to her then I would be subject to
disciplinary action up to and including
dismissal what did you make of that I
was shocked I think I cried a little bit
at first
I I didn't understand the overreach but
California is one of the 14 states in
the country that limit unreasonable
interference by administrators with
student newspapers and she sought help
from the student press Law Center by
then things were getting pretty ugly
there were some intimidating factors at
work and I was feeling pretty
uncomfortable at that point and what
kinds of things were the intimidating
factors did you think one of them was to
send a police officer who was waiting at
my door for me one morning questioning
me about sex trafficking and
distributing pornography to minors but
Kathy devil did not back down a group of
determined high schoolers in Stockton
have published a feature article on a
fellow student who works in the porn
industry the story in the school paper
the Bruin voice described how Caitlyn
fink considered her adult entertainment
career as a job just like any other job
as I'm sure everyone now sees the
content is not obscene in any way and
it's merely just showing the story of a
young student at our school who is on
her own living her independent life and
having to navigate the world of the
pornography industry and I feel though
that's an important story to tell and so
far the school has backed off its thread
to fire Kathy Duffy I am still employed
yes I think it's always a question she
receives support after national news
coverage of the showdown but most
important to her is the reaction of her
students she
such an inspiration and a role model to
everyone at school not just our class
and I'm glad that she's still here and
what is there inside of you that gave
you this kind of gumption I think
because this is not my first rodeo with
the district I have had some pretty
knock-down drag-out fights over the
years they've been hurtful and so I
still have something to prove I think to
this district that even after 33 years
me putting my job on the line means that
I am serious about free speech and I
will always hold them accountable
so our shout-out tonight to Cathy duffel
like many of us in this profession my
own career was launched at a high school
newspaper in Highland Park Illinois the
shoreline to this day I remember and
unthankful from all I learned my
journalism teacher dr. John muttski
that's our program for tonight thanks
for watching we'll see you back here and
next week